- If anything besides
being practical
and start making money
instead of losing money
is what you remember
from this talk this morning,
please make it that you need
to go to a senior citizen home
and volunteer for one day.
Here's what I want you to do.
Spend one day at a
senior citizen home
and I promise you you
will leave with the following.
You will leave that the
scariest thing in the world,
the scariest thing in the world
to human beings is regret.
What you will see in
those 80 and 90-year-olds,
some will be happy
and they'll be content,
but you will see
something at scale that scares
the living shit out of me.
It's called regret.
The amount of people
that wish they did things
is scary and let me
promise you something.
When you're 93,
it's hard to pull it off.
("Unbreakable" by Benjamin Katz)